so let's go ahead and work through an
actual curl computation let's say our
vector value function V which is a
function of XY and Z this is going to be
three-dimensional is defined by the
functions and I don't know let's say the
first component is x times y the second
one is cosine of Z and then the last
component is Z squared plus y let's say
so if you take this guy how do you
compute the curl curl of that vector
valued function so what do you do as I
mentioned in the last video as you
imagine taking this del operator and
taking the cross-product between that
and your vector valued function and what
that means when you expand it is that
del operator you just kind of fill it
with partial differential operators you
could say but really is just the symbol
partial partial X partial partial Y
partial palster partial partial Z and
these are things that are just waiting
to take in some kind of function so
we're going to take the cross-product
between that and the the function that
we have defined here so let me just
actually copy it over copy it over here
and little residue and to compute this
cross-product we take a certain
determinant so I'm going to write over
here determinant and it's going to be of
a 3x3 matrix but really it's kind of
like a quote-unquote matrix because each
component has something funky so the top
row just like we would have with any
other cross product that we're computing
is going to have I J and K these unit
vectors in three-dimensional space and
the second row here is going to have all
of these partial differential operators
since that's the first vector in our
cross-product
so that's partial partial X partial
partial Y and again all of these are
just kind of waiting to be given a
function that they can they can take the
derivative of and then that third row is
going to be the functions that we have
so the first component here is X Y the
second component is cosine of Z cosine
of Z and then that final component is Z
squared plus y Z squared plus y now so
I'll give some room here maybe make it
more visible
so this is the determinant we need to
compute and this is going to be broken
up into three different parts the first
one we take this top part I and multiply
it by the determinant of this sub matrix
so when we do that this sub determinant
we're taking partial derivative with
respect to Y of Z squared plus y now as
far as Y is concerned Z looks like a
constant so Z squared is a constant and
the partial derivative of this entire
guy is just 1 so that'll look like 1
and then we're subtracting off the
partial derivative with respect to Z of
cosine of Z and that just looks the same
as you know a derivative of cosine Z
which is negative sine so that's
negative sine of Z so that's the that's
the first part and then as the next part
we were gonna take J but we're
subtracting because you're always kind
of thinking plus minus plus when you're
doing these determinants so we're going
to subtract off J multiply it by its own
little sub determinant and this time the
sub determinant is going to involve the
2 columns that it's not part of so
you're imagining this first column and
the second column is being part of a
matrix so the first thing you do is you
take this partial derivative with
respect to X of Z squared plus y well no
X is show up there right that's Z
squared and Y each look like constants
as far as X is concerned so that's 0
then we take the partial with respect to
Z of x times y and again there's there's
no Z that shows up there so that's also
0 so it's kind of subtracting off 0 and
then finally we're adding this last
components we're going to add that last
component K multiplied by the
determinant of this sub matrix of the
columns that it's not part of so this
involves partial derivative with respect
to X of cosine Z well no X's show up
there so that's just 0 so that's just a
0 and then we're subtracting off the
partial with respect to Y of x times y
well X looks like a constant Y looks
like the variable so that partial
derivative is just X so we're
subtracting off X which means if we
simplify this so the curl of our vector
field curl of our vector field as a
whole
as this function of XY and Z is equal to
and that first component the the I
component we've got 1 minus negative
sine of Z so minus minus sine of Z
that's 1 plus sine of Z and then the J
component we're subtracting off but but
at 0 usually if you're subtracting off
you'd have to make sure to remember to
flip those but both of those are 0 so
the entire J component here or that the
Y component of the output is 0 and then
finally we're adding the the K component
is 0 minus X so that entire thing is
just negative X and that's the curl of
the function and in general that's how
you do it you would you would take a
look at the way that your function is
defined and each component there and
imagine taking the cross product between
this Dell symbol this partial partial X
partial partial Y partial partial Z and
you take the cross product between that
and your function and it involves taking
six different partial derivatives and
you just mainly it's a matter of
bookkeeping to make sure you do it right
and you'll end up with something like
this